im zollmuseum von hartkirchen hat
franz-josef ries alle hände voll zu tun
der pensionierte zöllner kümmert sich
ehrenamtlich um die ausstellung im alten
grenzhäuschen eigentlich ist die
deutsch-französische grenze hier
geschichte das museum ein symbol für
gute nachbarschaft
doch jetzt hat die korona krise einen
keil in die länderübergreifende
freundschaft getrieben
dass ich das noch erleben kann das was
deutsche mit dem franzosen irgendwelche
irgendwelchen kracher nur weise aus
frankreich kommen weil weil in
frankreich wo er war
das hätte ich nie im leben geglaubt dass
das wieder passiert franzosen werden
beschimpft stehen in verdacht das virus
zu verbreiten als die märz die grenzen
wieder geschlossen werden so wie diese
brücke eine deutsche behörde hatte die
französische nachbarregion zum
risikogebiet erklärt nur wer auf der
anderen seite arbeitete dürfte die
grenze weiter passieren eine maßnahme
für die franz josefs verständnis hat was
wollten sie wochen natürlich irgendwie
russ macht an keiner grenze der welt
halt die leute die rüberkommen mit dem
virus die vorbereitenden unten ihn hat
das schwer getroffen
warum man ist franzose pendelt zur
arbeit nach deutschland dann war über
nacht die grenze zu ohne ankündigung als
grenzgänger durfte er zwar über doch
mancher deutsche plötzlich eine gefahr
in ihm wenn man es trinke sie
unerwünschte und alles und das war das
etwa bild.de am herz gemacht warum mit
kindern extra ist jeder weiß es kommt ja
von china das hätte jetzt könnte die
deutsche kollege grün oder egal was und
mit kindern nichts davor dass das hat
man doch bewege dann im deutschen
grenzort gersheim hat der bürgermeister
selbst französische wurzeln wie man
schon an seinem namen merkt michael klie
wo hat die berichte gelesen von
grenzgängern aus frankreich die auf der
straße als scheiß franzosen beschimpft
wurden die in ihr kohrener land
zurückgehen sollten
ausgerechnet im frankophilen saarland
steht die deutsch französische
freundschaft auf dem prüfstand
in dieser krise hat sich tatsächlich
gezeigt dass sie vielleicht doch nicht
so stabil ist wie das uns bisher immer
vorgestellt haben und auch gewünscht
haben
und ich glaube dass wir jetzt einiges
auch noch mal tun müssen um zumindest
mal bei den menschen vor ort
dieses gefühl dass die partnerschaft so
wichtig für europa ist noch mal
tatsächlich aufzubauen
michael kleber hat das verhalten seiner
saarländer öffentlich kritisiert und
jetzt steht der selbst in der kritik
hier hat man tatsächlich news hier
vorgeworfen weil viele das auch nicht
wahrhaben wollten aber ich glaube es war
wichtig dass auch laut und stark zu
sagen dass wir hier ein problem haben
jetzt wo die grenze endlich wieder
geöffnet ist will der deutsche ein
zeichen setzen besucht seinen
französischen amtskollegen im
benachbarten remling wäre keiner erlebt
die freundschafts krise von der
französischen seite
er fürchtet die reaktionen aus
deutschland könnten narben hinterlassen
das hat ein klima des misstrauens
geschaffen in gewisser weise hat uns
unsere geschichte wieder eingeholt
da ist bei dem einen oder anderen
plötzlich wieder der extremismus
hochgekommen
das denkmal von remling zeugt von der
geschichte einer schwer umkämpften
grenzregion von den kriegen zwischen
beiden staaten eine mahnung für
politiker beider seiten sagen die
bürgermeister so manche unbedachte
äußerung habe die krise verschärft für
mich die politische rhetorik beeinflusst
auch das handeln der menschen und wie
sie mit der angst auch die im moment da
ist auch umgehen wenn wir natürlich über
wochen erzählt dass man die saarländer
vor dem franzosen schützen muss dann
fangen natürlich die menschen an darüber
nachzudenken und kommen dann vielleicht
zu ihrer zentralen handeln und das haben
wir hier auch gehabt so bekommt das alte
schild der europäischen freundschafts
brücke in hartkirchen wie der besondere
bedeutung franz-josef fries der
ehemalige kölner hätte es am liebsten
wieder am alten platz
eine freundschaft so fest war wie
deutschland und frankreich die gewachsen
ist über jahrzehnte wirklich über
jahrzehnte die macht man durch so ein
quatsch kaputt dass das jetzt bleibende
schäden hat
das kann ich meinen allerersten willen
nicht vorstellen absolut nicht im
kleinen museum von franz-josef ries wird
die korona blockade jedenfalls ihren
platz finden als ein neues stück
deutsch-französischer grenzgeschichte